I like the idea of the mountain just
kind of got a bit of a thing for Saracen
she's kind of cool you couldn't turn
your back on her she might be a bit of
fun
the Dragons this same gorge I fight like
pod and hang out with pod quite a bit
yeah so many beautiful women on the show
each and every one I think let's play
Facebook you'll be quite an exciting
exciting part or something like project
to be alone something quite as fiery as
I think maybe yeah I think that would be
very very cool to kind of like me pitch
I think I mean I think you know scary
devious man but I see so many if you
like I said mutually friendship Teutonic
thing very well miss kind of yeah it's
not much luck okay sounds like he's got
a beginning but I'd like to see Sam
spend some time with Joffrey as well
because I could think they could they
could learn a lot from each other maybe
a bit of marriage guidance counseling
with Melisandre how do we get hit it off
I really do I just put dragons yeah
seriously
all the White Walkers they kind of you
know maybe blush